[Musique]
il ya deux ans que que l'album précédent
a été sortie qui était une histoire
complète cette fois c'est de nouveau un
retour aux fondamentaux titov son album
de gags et
donc ça permet de traiter plus de sujets
quand c'est une histoire complètement on
développe une idée sur une longue
histoire là c'est titov qui papillonne
enfin c'est ce que je préfère faire avec
ce personnage saute d'un sujet à un
autre il la donne est déjà numéro 1 des
l'autre chez nous c'est chic
le succès s'arrête ne dément jamais bah
pour le moment pas donc c'est génial je
croise les doigts
il ya des planches sensibles notamment
la première sur le regard des autres des
planches plus dur mais toujours un
regard décalé sur l'actualité du trouble
immigrants l'état violence la pédophilie
en fait vous suivez l'actualité tous les
jours bon c'est de l'actualité qui est
qui est large qui a baigné un petit peu
cette année mais c'est le cas depuis le
début en fait dans titeuf
moi j'avais envie de faire une bande
dessinée contemporaine innovants
destinés qui parle du du monde dans
lequel on vit et puis et puis aussi
enfin j'avais envie que ce soit réaliste
même si je peux mon dessin n'est pas
réaliste mais j'avais envie de que ce
soit une bande dessinée dans laquelle on
retrouve les sujets contemporains parce
que je trouve que quand on est enfant on
ajoute cette idée que les enfants vivent
pas dans le même monde que les adultes
et donc ils sont un peu con plus leur
alors caché une partie des risques est
pas vrai les enfants et ils entendent
tout il y voit les pois les infos ils
entendent et même si on arrive à les
allées préserver d'une partie de la
réalité et leurs copains vont se charger
de l'irb rifaie à l'école est de leur
dire tout ce qu'ils ont raté donc ils
ont besoin de parler tout ça et titoff
il est là dedans donc pour moi c'est un
mélange de f1 c'est ce qui fait le
quotidien mais il n'y a pas des sujets
importants et à part des grands sujets
les petits sujets vu de l'âge de titoff
tout est sujet de curiosité mais il
n'est pas plus inquiète
du plan vigipirate que de l'interro qui
doit préparer en géographie ça fait
partie de son quotidien simplement un
petit et justement il a 25 ans cette
année porte sur bath il faut le voir
dans l'alba je ne peux pas vous le
résumé en une phrase mais il porte un
regard curieux c'est ce qui est
intéressant en fait c qui comprend pas
et qui tente de comprendre c'est
peut-être ce qui le différencie des
adultes on comprend pas mais on fait
comme si on avait compris